- [Instructor] Let's do another example
where we are projecting something
and it lands at a different level
and we'll also figure out
some other interesting things.
We'll figure out what the
actual velocity vector
is when it's landing, so both
its magnitude and its direction.
So let's do a situation.
So let's say we are launching
something from ground level,
and we're gonna launch it at a
pretty steep angle over here.
So let's say we launch it with an angle,
let's say we launch it with an angle of,
let me just, let's say it's 80 degrees.
We launch it at an 80
degree angle, at, let me.
We launch it at an 80 degree angle,
80 degree angle, and
it is going to be going
at 30 meters per second,
30 meters per second, so that's
the length of this vector,
that's the magnitude of that vector,
and let's say we want to
make it land on this landing,
and this landing right over here,
this landing right over here has a height,
this landing over here
has a height of 10 meters.
This height over here is 10 meters,
so what I wanna do first
of all is I wanna figure out
how far along the landing,
how far along the landing
do I actually land,
how far along the landing.
So, and maybe I'll add some
other information right here.
So say from this launching
point to the beginning
of the landing, let's say
that this right over here is two meters,
two meters, so we just want
to know how far along
the landing do we land.
So like we did before, we want to
break this vector into its horizontal
and vertical components,
its vertical and vertical components,
and I'm gonna go a little
bit faster in this video,
'cause hopefully we're getting the knack
for this type of thing.
So our velocity, our
velocity in the vertical
or our vertical component
of our velocity is going to
be equal to the magnitude
of our total velocity,
30 meters per second,
times, and it's going to
be the sine of 80 degrees,
'cause sine is opposite over hypotenuse,
times the sine of 80 degrees,
and our, and we'll just get
it out of the way right now,
the horizontal component
of our velocity is going
to be 30 meters per second,
and I'm not writing the units here,
just to save space, times
the cosine of 80 degrees.
Once again, cosine is adjacent,
adjacent, adjacent over hypotenuse,
and if you feel like I'm skipping steps,
in the last few videos, I go
into this in much more detail.
So, how much time do we spend in the air?
How much time do we spend in the air?
So, once again, in the last few videos,
we saw that we can look at our,
we can look at displacement,
if we want to figure out time in the air,
we know that displacement is
equal to the initial velocity,
initial velocity times time,
plus acceleration, let me
write times change in times,
since that's more technically,
that's technically more correct,
plus acceleration times change
in time squared, over, over two.
Now, in our situation, we know
what our initial velocity is,
we are talking about the vertical
direction right over here,
so our initial velocity
is going to be this.
We are trying to figure
out how time in the air,
and the vertical
component determines that,
because at some point, when
it hits back to the ground,
it's not gonna be traveling anymore,
so that's what's determining
its time in the air.
So we know that, we know the acceleration.
Remember, our convention,
when we are dealing with
the vertical dimension
is up is positive, down is negative,
so this is negative 9.8
meters per second squared,
and then we can, and then
what is the total displacement
that we are gonna have?
Well, we are starting at ground level,
and we are just talking about
the vertical, remember that.
So our total displacement
is going to be 10 meters,
so this value right here
so it simplifies to 10 meters,
I won't write the units here,
is equals 10 is equal to,
what's 30 sine of 80 degrees?
So we have 30 times the sine
of 80 degrees, gives us 29.54.
29.54.
So this is 29.54 times our change in time,
times our change in time,
and so this is negative
9.8 divided by two,
so it's negative, I'll
do that same green color,
four point, that's not
the same green color,
negative 4.9 meters per second squared.
I'm not writing the units here,
times delta t squared,
and then we can subtract
10 from both sides
and write this in a traditional
quadratic equation form,
so we get negative, and I'm
gonna flip the sides too,
negative 4.9 times delta t squared,
and then we have, plus
29.54 times delta t,
minus 10, minus 10 is equal to zero,
and then we can use the quadratic
formula to find the roots
of this, so the delta t's
that satisfy this quadratic equation are
going to be negative b,
so negative 29.54, plus
or minus the square root of 29.54 squared,
b squared, minus four, minus four,
times a, which is negative 4.9,
for the negative times a
negative is a positive.
So it's plus four times
positive 4.9, times,
or I shouldn't have, I
shouldn't have jumped so fast
to get rid of the negative.
So it's gonna be minus four times a,
which is negative 4.9, times c,
which is negative 10, so just a times c,
negative 4.9 times negative 10, let me
just write negative 4.9 times
negative 10, these two guys,
their signs are going to cancel out.
All of that, all of that
over, all of that over two a.
All of that over negative 4.9
times two, so negative 9.8.
And like we saw in the last video,
we want a positive value for this.
A negative time is nonsensical,
that's kind of going into the past,
so we want a positive value.
And since we have a
negative in the denominator,
we want to have a negative value up here,
and if we already have
a negative value here,
if we have subtract
from that native value,
we're definitely gonna have
a negative value up here,
and then you divide by a negative value,
we'll get a positive value,
so we can really focus on
the subtracting the radical,
and you could try it out.
If you tried the positive version,
you're gonna get a negative
value for this entire thing.
Do that on, you can try
that out after this video,
just to verify that you
get a nonsensical answer.
So let's use a negative right over here,
so we have negative 29.54
minus the square root of,
the square root of 29.54 squared,
and then we have minus four,
minus four, times negative 4.9
times negative 10, these two,
when you take the product,
it's positive 49, so times,
times 49, and I should add
a parentheses over there,
so let me insert a parentheses.
You can insert parentheses,
okay, so times 49.
So this right here will
give me the numerator
if I evaluate this, got me negative value,
and I divide that by negative 9.8, so
divided by negative 9.8
gives me 5.67, 5.67 seconds.
This is equal to 5.67 seconds,
and you could keep the units in there
and make sure that all of the
dimensional analysis works,
and I think you'll find that it does.
So our total, our total vertical,
the total time in the air
is 5.6, the total time in
the air is 5.67 seconds.
Now, what I want to do,
the whole point of this is to figure out,
is to figure out how far
along this landing we land.
Well, our horizontal component
of our velocity is right over here.
We know that, we know
that our displacement
in the horizontal direction,
our displacement in the
horizontal direction will be
our velocity in the horizontal direction,
and it's a constant velocity,
so it's the same thing
as our average velocity
in the horizontal direction,
times the change in time.
Well, the change in time is,
so I'll just that times,
our change in time.
So this is going to be equal
to 30 cosine of 80 degrees,
30 cosine of 80 degrees,
times 5.67 seconds, times 5.67 seconds,
and this, I won't write the units.
This is meters per second times seconds,
it'll give us an answer in meters.
So once again, we have,
this is our time, this is
the 5.67, times 30 cosine
of 80 degrees, gives us 29.53 meters.
So our total horizontal traveling,
displacement I guess, we could say,
is 29, I already forgot
the number, 29.53 meters.
29.53 meters, and I'll
write this as a vector,
that is our horizontal displacement,
it's equal to 29.53 meters.
Now, we've done a lot of
deconstructing vectors,
what I thought would be
interesting in this video
is to construct a vector.
So we know our horizontal displacement.
We also know our vertical displacement,
it's positive 10 meters, so
what's our total displacement?
Let me write this down.
So we have a horizontal displacement.
We have a horizontal
displacement of 29.53 meters,
and we have a vertical
displacement of plus 10 meters.
We have a vertical displacement
of positive 10 meters,
and so what is our total displacement?
What is our total
displacement going to be?
Well, we could use the
Pythagorean theorem now here.
The square of the magnitude
of our total displacement is
going to be equal to the sum
of these two squares, or another way,
this is just the Pythagorean theorem,
so we could have, if we call
this length over here c,
or let me just write it,
this is the magnitude of our
displacement right over here,
the magnitude of our total
displacement squared is
going to be equal to 10
squared plus 29.53 squared.
So it's going to be 10
I'm gonna do that same
color, plus 29.53 squared.
If we want to solve for this,
we just take the square
root of both sides,
so I'll just do that in place.
So if we just take the
square root of both sides,
we will get the magnitude
of our total displacement,
and I can get the calculator
out once again to do that.
So the magnitude of our total displacement
is the square root of, 10 squared
is just 100, plus 29, I can even use,
well, I could use all of this information,
so that I don't even lose some precision.
I could say second answer,
that literally means the previous answer,
which is that 29.53 squared,
gives us a total
displacement of 31.18 meters.
So this is equal to 31.18 meters,
and of course, it's a vector,
so we've only given you the magnitude,
we also need the direction.
So one way to specify direction
is to give you the angle
with the horizontal,
and let's call that angle theta,
and once again, we can use our trig,
our trig functions over here.
We could use pretty much
any of the trig functions,
but we know the opposite side
is 10, we know the hypotenuse here
is 31.18, so why not use sine,
sine is opposite over hypotenuse.
So we know that the sine
of theta is going to be
equal to 10 over 31.18.
10 over 31.18, or if you
want to solve for theta,
you take the arcsine of both sides,
or the inverse sine of both sides,
you get theta is equal to the inverse sine
or I could write arcsine over
here, of 10, of 10 over 31.8.
10 over 31.18, I should say.
So let's once again get the
calculator out to figure out
that value, so I'm gonna
take the inverse sine.
Once again, so this is the
same thing as the arcsine.
This just says, give me the angle
that when I take its sine,
I get this value right over here,
so the inverse sine of 10
divided by our previous answer, 31.18.
I'll just say that our
previous answer is equal to,
so this says, give me the angle
whose sine is 10 over 31.18.
So I have 18.7 degrees,
or 18.71 degrees, so this
is equal to 18.71 degrees,
18.71 degrees above the horizontal.
So here we've constructed a vector,
we took its vertical component
and its horizontal component
and we were able to figure
out the total vector,
so this projectile in this situation is,
its total displacement,
so just to make it clear,
its path will look something like this,
its path will look something like this.
Its path is gonna look
something like this,
and we've just calculated
its total displacement,
its total displacement is 31.18 meters,
18.71 degrees above the horizontal.
And the other thing I've realized
is when I started this problem,
I asked you, I think I was asking you
how far along the platform,
and we've figured out its
total horizontal displacement,
so if you wanna know how
far along the platform,
the platform starts two
meters to the right,
so it's really 27.53 meters along
the platform is where it lands.